[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL NASH: So good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Paul Nash and
I manage the product team
for Google Compute Engine.
So today is an update from last
year's talk, which was called
Saving Money on Compute Engine.
So this year it is Saving
More Money on Compute Engine.
It's right there.
So just out of curiosity,
how many of you
might have seen that talk
either online or last year
even, by show of hands?
Excellent, good.
All my jokes are good then.
But to get a little sense of
what we're going to do here,
I'm going to show you all the
different ways that we have
where you can save more
money on Compute Engine.
Apart from the fact that all
of you are new, how many of you
are currently Google
customers that
are using either
GCE or a product
that you believe runs
on Compute Engine?
Show of hands.
OK, great.
Awesome, thank you.
So now a little bit of a quiz.
Sorry, it's after lunch.
I did request the
comfortable chairs for you.
Please don't fall asleep, but
I won't take it personally
if you do.
But I have a little bit
of audience participation
just to get you thinking
about this space.
So this is going to be
like a game on "Price
is Right" called That's
Too Much, I believe.
What I'd like you to
do is raise your hands
and keep them up if you
believe that, on average,
customers waste at least 10% of
their spend on Compute Engine,
10%.
OK, so if you think it's
at least 10% but not more
than 15%, put your hands down.
If you think it's 15% or
more, keep your hands up.
OK.
What about 20%?
30%?
40%?
Yeah.
So it turns out it's about 35%.
Now, this particular stat
comes to us from Rightscale.
They do a broad survey of
cloud adopters every year.
And the number that
they actually measure--
customers they're
working with-- is 35%.
Interestingly, it turns out
that the customers they survey
think the number is 30%.
So they're already
pretty pessimistic
about their efficiency.
But then they're not even
as pessimistic as reality.
So it shouldn't be any surprise
then that those customers also
say that--
76% of them-- that spend control
is one of their challenges.
About a third of those say
that it's one of their most
significant challenges.
And over half of them say that
it's their top focus for 2018.
So presumably some
of those reasons
might be why you're here today.
And so we're going to talk
about some of the things
that you can take advantage
of on Compute Engine
to address that concern.
So before I go any
further, usually this slide
comes at the end, but this
is an important enough topic.
Obviously, we've
put a lot of effort
into making sure that we have
a lot of great content for you
here at Cloud Next
over the coming days.
And so I wanted to call
out some of the other great
presentations that you can
either see here or catch
on YouTube that go into some
of the more detail on some
of the tools and techniques that
are outside Compute Engine's
features itself but within
our billing support systems
that you can use to help
you with this problem.
And I'll give you
a little preview
of some of those at the end.
So since food is probably on
the minds of a lot of people
here, or maybe not
because you just ate,
I thought I would keep
this a little bit light.
I have a little bit of a
metaphor running through
as if this were a cooking show.
And I'm going to teach you how
to cook up an efficient Cloud
bill.
So bear with me.
I won't overstretch the
metaphor too much hopefully.
But I'm going to start with
sharing some basic ideas
about cooking your
bill, and then
move on to some
of the ingredients
that you can play with
to get the best outcome.
And then I'll talk
about some recipes
that you should try at home.
And then we have some
gadgets at the end.
So chopping onions.
That's kind of where most
people start with cooking.
That's a good thing to learn.
So what are some of the basic
ideas about cost management
that you should
be thinking about
as you're looking about
how you use Compute Engine?
Well, so first of all, we're
working on pricing innovations.
And when we're thinking
about what do we want to do,
we keep three core
principles in mind.
And those are the
ones you see here.
It should be simple,
it should be flexible,
and it should be fair.
So those are big
words and they can
mean a lot of different things.
I'm going to tell you what they
mean to me and to our team when
we're working on these things.
And we think that these
are the ideals that
represent what customers tell
us they would like to have.
And so we really try
to keep those in mind.
So that guy was pretty smart.
He had a good idea.
Simple is nice to say,
but obviously, Cloud
is a very complicated space.
So what does it mean to have a
very simple approach to pricing
in a complex space?
It doesn't mean everything
is exactly the same price.
It doesn't mean
there's not any dials
or knobs you can optimize.
What it should mean is that
the concepts are simple,
that it's easy for
you, as a customer,
to understand how it works,
how changes would happen
if you make changes
to your usage,
and then it all
kind of makes sense.
So you don't have to have a PhD
in economics, a PhD in physics,
or a team of people
figuring out how this works.
You can kind of hold
it in your head.
That's the idea of simple
that we're going for.
So like I said, simple to
understand, simple to use,
but powerful enough
to meet your needs.
And you have a lot of complex
needs as a set of customers.
There's a lot of
different use cases.
And so we want to be able to
capture those and make sure
that what you're getting
works for your situation,
but no rocket science, and
definitely not hidden costs.
So then what does flexible mean?
Well, like I said,
across our customer
base there is a very broad
set of different use cases.
Not all businesses are alike.
Not all teams are thinking
about spending in the same way.
That might be
because the finance
department or the IT
division or whoever
thinks about how
this money is spent
might have a different approach
to how the controls work
within that company.
It might be that
you're a startup,
and the finance department
is Joe or Sally,
and it's their credit card.
Or it might be a much
more complex situation.
We have another talk, actually,
that talks about how you could
scale that whole challenge.
Also, your needs are
going to change over time.
So something that you
bought 18 months ago
or signed up for three years
on, if it's not flexible enough,
it's not going to meet your
needs by the end of your time.
So we think a lot about that.
And what that really boils
down to in our product
is that you should be
able to pay for what
you need, not anything more.
And you shouldn't have regrets
when those things do change,
or feel like you
can't make changes,
because then you wouldn't be
efficient with your spend.
And finally, fair.
So I have a bunch--
I have three small kids.
And my five-year-old-- I'm
sure you know the phrase,
but that's not fair.
So we're working a lot on
what the word fair means.
It doesn't mean what
he thinks it means.
What it means in
this context is what
works for Google works for you.
So Moore's law happens, prices
go down for our components,
performance goes up.
You should see that
reflected, just as
if you were buying
the machines yourself.
You should always be
getting a great price.
And you should always be
getting a great value.
So a lot of times we talk about
price performance, not just
price.
That also has led to some of the
innovative features that we've
brought out, such as
automatic discounts.
You don't have to ask us or
learn the secret trick to know
how to use the discount.
It just happens.
We think that's a pretty
cool innovation that is fair.
If it's more efficient
for us to run,
we should give you some of
that back as a discount.
It also has led to
us building tools
like rightsizing
recommendations, which
is if you're overspending,
we will actually say,
hey, you're overspending.
You should stop doing that.
That's a little counterintuitive
for a for-profit company,
right?
We're telling you to
spend less with us.
But we believe that that is
the fair and right thing to do,
and that either you will
use that somewhere else
for something that
is valuable to you
or we will sell it
to another customer.
And we're happy either way.
And then finally,
we want to give you
smart tools and the
data that you need to be
able to monitor and control it.
So there's no questions
about what you're spending.
That's what we think fair means.
OK.
So some terminology.
Different people are
at different places.
But I want to
highlight a few things
that we have customer
conversations with quite
frequently.
And the first one
is what's a core?
What's a vCPU?
What's a physical core?
What's a virtual core?
So on the left is a somewhat
older generation x86 CPU.
And if you squint
you can see here
there are four what I
call physical cores,
actual execution units that have
all of their stuff duplicated.
It's actually a mirror image.
And there's four
of those on there.
So a lot of times a
customer will come to us
and say, well, I have
a four core machine.
If you bought this processor
it would be called a quad core
Intel CPU.
But there's a technology
called hyper-threading,
which I'm sure many of
you are familiar with,
which essentially allows
each of those cores
to run two different paths of
execution at the same time.
So in Cloud, those
are commonly exposed
of as what we'd call a
virtual core independently,
or a vcore, or a vCPU.
So it's kind of little
something like that.
So that's a four core processor.
If we were selling that
as a VM, which we wouldn't
do because that's not enough
cores to put in a server,
but if we were
selling that, that
would be an eight vCPU machine.
And we would sell an
eight vCPU VM on it.
Seems obvious, perhaps,
but the difference is 2x.
So if you're analyzing
your costs incorrectly
thinking about what you
need, the difference
can be significant.
And so when we're having
conversations with customers
about what size
their VM should be
and how that scales, in
particular if they're migrating
something from an
on-prem environment,
this is a topic that
comes up very often.
So I wanted to
highlight it here.
So count those cores carefully.
But the thing is,
our hardware might
be newer than what you have, the
performance might be different.
Your software may
or may not be clock
rated or thread sensitive.
So it's not always quite
as straightforward as 2x,
and we'll talk a little
bit later about why
it's important to measure that.
But it is important
to look at this.
Now, the other thing
to keep in mind
is that you may have
software licenses.
For example, Microsoft licenses
either for Windows Server
or for SQL Server
tend to measure
in terms of physical cores.
Sometimes when
you move to Cloud,
they decide to use
that same license
to apply to a virtual core.
And that can change your costs.
So that's another
thing to be aware of.
Also, I want to talk about
analyzing your needs.
So looking across
clouds, for example,
list prices are not
exactly the same.
The machines are not
necessarily the same.
The way that you pay is
not necessarily the same.
You're not actually
likely to pay list price
unless you're doing a very
unusual usage pattern.
But the list prices
still are not the same.
So if that's where you
start your analysis,
you're already not
quite looking at it
the way it's going to
show up on your bill.
You need to understand how
the different clouds discount
differently and what your usage
pattern is going to look like.
So this kind of leads to
a similar tip, which is
think about your analysis.
Try to come as close as you can
to modeling what your usage is
really going to look like.
A lot of times a proof
of concept use case
can help with this.
So finally, that broad idea of
understanding what your usage
is.
What are the underlying trends?
How peaky or spikey is
your workload going to be?
And then once you
understand that,
it's important to
also understand
that the true utilization-- what
I'll call true utilization--
is not actually how many
cores you've deployed.
If they're all idle, you're not
getting any value out of those.
And so the ROI on those
you can call zero.
You're paying for
something you're not using.
I would say it's actually
negative, because it's still
burning power.
And so when you're
thinking about comparing
one situation to another, it's
important to keep that in mind.
Finally, TCO-- that's not
usually what it stands for,
but it's a very
confusing topic so that's
what I'm going to call it today.
So customers
oftentimes when they're
calculating their
internal TCO, this
turns into a big conversation
about what have they included,
what have they not included.
The point that I
want to make here,
though, is that
even once you get
that whole financial analysis
you're kind of not done.
Because your on-prem
configuration is a much longer
time frame environment.
So from your finance
department, you'll
hear, well, our TCO is x dollars
or x cents per core hour.
And that's on a
machine that maybe
has a three year or a five year
depreciation schedule depending
on your refresh.
But guess what?
That hardware's out
of date in 18 months.
So you have it for another year
and a half to 3 and 1/2 years.
And that's what you get on it.
You're not getting
performance upgrades.
You may not have
other accelerators
that you can plug into it.
You may not be able to upgrade
your racks to have more power.
You may not be able to
change your networking gear.
You may not be able
to resize your disks
by making a single click.
So there's a lot of other
limitations and flexibility
you lose in that calculation.
And that doesn't always show
up in the actual dollars
per watt kind of calculation.
So it's important consideration
to keep in mind when
you're thinking about
whether the prices are
apples to apples.
OK, so let's talk about
some of the ingredients that
go into our cost saving
souffle, if you will.
First of all, the way we
think about it at Google
is there's a set
of base resources.
Pretty much
fundamentally, a computer
is a processing unit
and some RAM for data.
And then there's some I/O that
brings the data in and out.
So in a lot of places
where you might deploy,
that ratio of how many vCPUs
to how much gigabytes of RAM
is fixed, or at least it's fixed
among a small set of options.
The problem with that is it
might not match your workload.
So that's one aspect.
The second aspect
is what we would
think of as the attached
resources, things
that you could imagine you're
plugging into a server.
In reality, they
may already be there
or your VM is just going to
be assigned to a server that
happens to have those things.
And then you're going to
use them when you need them.
But how do you
think about those?
Are those essentially
welded into the VM
that you need to buy?
Or do you get to
choose dynamically
or in a very granular way what
you need and then pay for that?
So looking at that and thinking
about the problem that way
and thinking about having
a decomposed solution
led us to looking at this idea
of alphabet letters and shapes
and sizes and Z1 and X7
and all of this stuff.
And the fact that those have
these pre-configured shapes
of what you're going to get.
You're going to get a
certain vCPU in RAM ratio.
You're going to get
certain devices plugged in.
And the providers
that do it that way
are trying to guess at what
your use case is going to be.
But they're doing one guess
for a broad set of customers.
And even within those use cases,
things might be different.
So if you want to use
a bunch of NVIDIA GPUs,
you might have very
different use cases
and very different patterns that
mean you need more CPU, less
CPU, more RAM, less RAM.
So when you're
thinking about cost,
you need to think about
the fact that it's not just
the dollars per hour
cost of that VM,
that pre-configured shape.
If you're not using
some of those resources,
you're just paying for
waste that you don't need.
Now, it turns out that
getting this right
and doing this in a decomposed
way is a really tricky problem.
Fortunately, Google
internally uses
a system called Borg
to manage our fleet.
And you've probably
read a little bit
about that in the
press, maybe not.
But that's how we managed
our fleet for over a decade.
And it's gotten
very good at having
flexible definition
of what a job uses
and how many resources it needs.
And it understands how to
pack those things together
in an efficient way.
And Compute Engine is built on
top of that core technology.
And it uses and
leverages all of that.
So for us, having more flexible
definition of what a VM is
was an easy thing to
do, because we already
had that infrastructure there.
If you don't have that
infrastructure, making
everything scale in a
fixed size and ratcheting
it up by powers of two makes for
a relatively simple scheduling
problem.
And you can efficiently
schedule the machine.
The problem is any waste is
the customer's responsibility
to pay for.
And that's not what we wanted
to end up with in our design.
OK, so what are
some of the things
you can do with
these ingredients,
as it were, on Compute Engine
to cook up some savings?
So the direction
I've been leading
with the last
couple of slides is
talking about where we landed
with custom machine types.
So if you haven't seen
this feature before,
essentially the idea is
pick the ratio you want,
decide what you want
attached, and you're done.
That's what you pay for.
So we allow for any increments
of either from one vCPU
and then any multiple of two
up to the largest machine
size that we offer.
And RAM within a very
broad ratio of about 0.9
gigabytes to 6.5
gigabytes per CPU.
So it's a ratio range that you
can tune in quarter gigabyte
increments.
So what that means
is pretty much
any ratio you've got out there,
unless it's 14 to 1, 16 to 1
on RAM, you can build your
own custom machine type that
matches that ratio exactly.
Then you can pick
how much storage
you want to attach to it.
You can pick if you
want local SSD attached
to it, GPUs, Cloud TPUs.
You configure that and then
that's what you pay for.
And we show you the prices
of those individual units.
So one of the
things that we found
is that this was very
helpful for customers
that are doing
migrations, particularly
from on-prem, where in the past,
processor manufacturers have
made machines that are six
cores or processors that
are six cores, 12, 14, 18.
Those aren't powers of 2.
So if you're actually looking to
migrate an existing application
without many changes, the thing
that might make the most sense
is to be able to size it into
a VM that exactly matches
the same number of resources.
And so this lets you do that.
Now, we'll talk
in a minute about
whether or not that's
as far as you could
go in optimizing your spend.
But it's a reasonable starting
point and it helps you already.
So if you thought
about what you'd
do migrating to a cloud that
didn't have that option, if you
need 10 vCPUs, and your only
option is one that has 16,
you're already 60% over
on processing power.
So what do you do?
Do you squeeze it down to eight?
Do you run 16 and hope it's OK
and just take the extra costs?
You don't have to make
that choice on Google.
Another thing that we
see is for some reason--
it's pretty strange,
we're not really sure--
a lot of people run
2 gigabytes per vCPU.
We do actually know the reason.
It's because that's a ratio
that exists on another cloud.
So it's very easy to port over
from that perspective as well.
It's not a ratio that we
offer in our predefined types,
but it is a common ratio.
So it can help with
that too if you just
want to minimize your changes.
The nice thing about this is you
can also just optimize later.
You can start where
it makes sense,
and then if you want to go
spend some time maybe doing
some deep analysis
of your application
later, figure out exactly
how much RAM you really need,
just move the dial,
turn down the RAM.
Or maybe you're finding
that your server is sitting
idle, you need fewer
processors, move the dial,
turn down the processors.
And then a quick reboot
and you're good to go.
We'd like to get
rid of the reboot,
but it turns on a lot of guest
operating systems require it.
So maybe some day.
But wait, there's more.
We'll actually
help you with this.
So last year, we talked about
right sizing recommendations
a little bit.
At that time, the
feature was in beta.
It's now generally available.
And this was actually a snapshot
of part of the Cloud console.
And so the feature is
the right-hand column.
Essentially, we will watch
your VM from the outside,
without seeing any of the data.
We look at the usage of
CPU utilization, RAM,
page utilization.
And we can figure out how much
you are leaving idle and not
using.
And after we've watched
that for a while,
we will make a recommendation
to you about a different shape
you could pick.
Oftentimes, it's going
to be a custom shape that
will allow you to save money.
We evaluate the RAM and
CPU dimensions separately.
So essentially, we're
moving the knob for you
on custom machine types.
And then it's with one-click
you can apply that.
In addition, we currently have
in beta this same capability,
but for Managed Instance
Groups that are not autoscaled.
So autoscaling is a
little bit harder problem,
because you're essentially
scaling horizontally.
So what does it mean to resize
any individual instance is
a trickier thing.
But we see people use
Managed Instance Groups
for scenarios like a cluster of
database machines, for example.
It's not one that
changes in size.
But it might be that each
of those individual machines
are oversized in one
or both dimensions.
So that capability
is also there.
Now, one caveat I'll
mention and the other reason
why we do have the button for
you to click and confirm it
is there are outlier cases
where you might actually
intentionally want that
machine to be over-provisioned.
And an example I
would give you is
if you have a certain
latency target on, say,
a query response
from a server, you
might need the processor
to be not fully utilized so
that you can hit that reliably.
Because when it starts to
get highly utilized, then
you're going to get
more variance at you're
P90 or your P99.
So there are some cases where
that doesn't necessarily
make sense, but for
most people this really
helps you move the dial
on what your spend is
and how much is wasted.
So another thing that we
do a little bit differently
on Google Cloud to help
you save automatically
is Sustained Use Discounts.
So the core idea
here is very simple.
The more you run the
more you save, up to 30%
if you run a VM for
the whole month.
Now, it turns out that's
fairly straightforward,
but that use case of
you have to run it
for exactly the whole
month might not always
happen in production scenarios.
Like, let's say you need
to reboot or upgrade
or you move to a different
zone or instance type.
There are some of
those scenarios where
it wouldn't be fair, if you
refer to the principles,
for us to say, yep.
Nope, sorry.
You don't get the discount
because you didn't
meet these type of criteria.
The actual concept here is
if your usage is steady,
it's more efficient for us to
provide the service for you.
And so in that case, we're very
happy to give you a discount.
So we came up with a concept
called inferred instances that
actually looks at all the
different instances that
are the same size within a
zone and looks at their usage
together and tries to create the
idea that these instances that
were really separate but
running at different times,
they could have all been run
together as if they were one.
And it makes no
difference to us.
So we stack that
together and give you
the discount for the longest
timespan that we can find.
The reason we can do
this, incidentally,
is because for us this
billing, discounts, et cetera,
is just essentially
a big data problem.
It runs a big MapReduce.
And if you remember
what MapReduce is,
that's what Google calls Hadoop.
And so it's very
simple for us to just
have something like this.
It's complex for us to
process but simple for you
to take advantage of,
because turns out,
we like big data
problems at Google.
So with that said, one of
the things that we saw we
could make better,
and you'll see--
I was asked to put the roadmap
note on the top of this slide.
This is not available quite
yet, but it's coming very soon--
is we're moving
from a model where
sustained use discount used
to combine only within a zone.
We're moving to a model where
it will combine across all
of the zones within a region.
And the idea there
is over time, we've
made it clear that we
believe the right way
to build a highly
reliable application
is to spread your workload
across multiple zones.
And what we've seen is more
and more customers are actually
doing that.
But the downside
of that, and this
goes back to that idea
of fairness again,
is if you did what
we suggested you
do to have a great service,
you're going to be giving up
discount, because
now your machines are
across different zones.
And in fact, maybe
you're actually
not multi-zone for
some of your things,
but for one reason
or another, you
decide to move to
a different zone.
Perhaps, sometimes not all of
our capabilities, like a GPU,
for example, is available
in every single zone,
and you've started
adding GPU usage
and you want to move zones.
Well, you shouldn't be
penalized because you moved.
So we're getting
rid of that barrier,
and we're moving SUD to change
so that it works across all
the zones in a region.
And this will be
rolling out pretty soon.
I'm not going to give an exact
timeline now, but stay tuned.
There will be a blog
announcement about that.
And that's just an example
of we found a better way
and we want to
bring that to you.
So I talked about those
inferred instances a minute ago.
And you can imagine that
when we do that rollout,
these inferences will
now apply across all
the zones in the region.
And that's true, except
I'm happy to report
that I'm going to be able to
retire this slide pretty soon.
This was one of
the oldest diagrams
I think we have in our docs.
It's hard to read.
Takes a little while to
understand what it means.
It turns out we have
an even better idea.
So we're going to be getting
rid of this whole concept
of inferred instances.
And what we're doing
instead is something we're
calling resource-based pricing.
So we got a lot of
feedback from customers
that you love Sustained
Use Discounts.
But that diagram is kind
of hard to understand.
And more importantly, it's
very hard for you to model.
So a lot of customers like
to have their own system, be
it a spreadsheet or
another mechanism,
that essentially calculates
what our billing system is going
to calculate and helps
you accurately predict
what your spend is going to be.
Maybe that's in order to
model a new application you're
deploying.
Maybe it's because you're
considering a migration.
Or maybe it's just you like to
have a different system that
keeps track of what you
think your bill should be so
that you can look
for any anomalies
and try to understand them.
So it's very hard to model.
So we're getting rid of it.
And what we'll be doing
instead is actually
a model that's very similar
to what we already do
with Committed Use Discounts.
And I'll explain that a
little bit more in a second.
But essentially,
we're just moving
to it's all buckets
of vCPUs and RAM.
And we will look at all
of your usage across time
and give you the best
Sustained Use Discount we can.
So the way to think of that
might be low watermarks,
essentially.
So I have a simple
scenario of what
this is going to look like.
And you can actually see
there's documentation up
for this today.
But again, this will take
a little while for us
to roll out.
One of the reasons we're
talking about it today
is because we recognize that
this is a change to the system.
And even though it's a change
that's completely in customers'
favor, it's different.
And so we want to
talk with customers,
explain what's going
to happen, make sure
that you're all ready, so
that when this shows up,
it's not a shock and it's
not a problem if you're
expecting something
different on your bill.
So imagine this scenario.
You're running a
server, you happen
to use one of our
predefined types.
Our main line type is
the standard series.
So you have an n1-standard-4,
it's four vCPUs.
And this is a database
server for your backend.
It's not dynamically
autoscaled, but it's
sized according to what
you expect your load to be.
But you know that
your CEO is going
on "Shark Tank" in a week.
And you're expecting a big
hit in traffic, big jump up.
And it's going to stay
that way for a while.
So you'd like to scale
up to a 16 vCPU database
because you believe that's
what you're going to need.
So how would Sustained Use
apply in that scenario?
So in the old model, these two
instance types are different.
And just assume for
the moment that these
are the only instances
you're running.
Obviously, reality's a
little more complicated.
But let's say that
there weren't really
any other four vCPU
instances that you
were running that would infer
together with your database.
And there weren't any
other 16 vCPU instances
that you were running before
you upgraded your database.
Well, in that case,
if you switched
in the middle of
the month, you'd
only get the 10% tier
Sustained Use Discounts
for each of those
machines in that month.
It's still-- it's nice.
But if you'd been running
the database all month,
you would have got 30%.
So what if we just recognized
that those four cores are still
four cores, four vCPUs, and give
you the max 30% on those four,
and then give you that
10% on the other 12?
And then next month you'd
get 30% on those 16.
That's essentially
resourced-based pricing.
And it turns out, like
I said, we already
count this way if you're
using Committed Use Discounts.
And in fact, if you are using
Committed Use Discounts,
then Sustained
Use Discounts also
already work this
way for any usage
that goes above your
commitment level,
because otherwise they
wouldn't play together nicely.
But now we're just rolling
this out for everybody.
So all usage will see this.
So if you'd like to know more,
the docs link is up today.
There are a couple of things
you should think about,
how this fits with your
model with your tools.
I'll give you one example,
which is also mentioned
in the docs in more detail.
If you're using
BigQuery billing export,
if you're looking at the SKU to
understand what kind of machine
you're using, those SKUs
are going to disappear.
You won't see an n1-standard-4
SKU usage anymore.
All it's going to be is
four units of vCPU usage.
So it will say something like
vCPU North America is one core.
There is another field,
though, called machine_spec.
It's a system tag that comes
out that tells you what
that machine was configured as.
So if you're looking for
detailed machine information,
you may want to use that tag--
sorry, label-- or you may
want to set up your own labels
to make sure that you have
the metadata you want in order
to analyze your billing.
And that's an example of
one of the reasons why we're
previewing this announcement.
So we like SUD.
Our customers like SUD.
But then they also said,
hey, it resets every month.
But I know I'm going to be
running this workload for 12
months or more.
Can you do you a mega
Sustained Use Discount, just
super sustained?
So we thought about that
for a little bit, started
talking to customers.
And they said, oh,
yeah, also, can you
do it without any machine
size restrictions and no zone
restrictions to
get the discount?
I want to be able to
move things around.
And I don't want to pay you
all up front because cash flow.
So basically, all
the flexibility
and no restrictions.
Can we have that?
So we thought about
that and we said, OK.
So that's Committed
Use Discounts.
We introduced this
product last year.
Again, it was a product
that was in beta
at the time Next happened.
And it went GA before
the end of the year.
Essentially, the concept
here is we give you
the maximum flexibility and the
maximum discounts that we can.
All we ask is that
you tell us if it's
going to be one
year or three years
that you're willing
to sign up for.
And the discounts vary
between those two.
Then you tell us what region--
not which zone-- but we do have
to do some capacity planning
to make sure that those
machines are there.
And then tell us how many
vCPUs and RAM you want.
And now you'll see
where this is the mirror
of resource-based pricing
for Sustained Use Discounts.
It's just vCPUs and RAM.
You use it however you want.
That's it.
So thinking about those
principles I mentioned,
seems pretty simple, hopefully.
Just a few decisions
to make that you
should have a pretty
good idea of if you're
looking at your workload,
analyzing your bill.
One of the nice things about
this is because-- what we find
is that it has enough
flexibility that you can pretty
safely buy up to
the low watermark
of your monthly usage, or
usage over some period of time
that you believe is
representative of your needs,
and be pretty sure that all
of that is going to be used.
So we have a number of
customers that tell us
that they're
regularly seeing well
above 90% utilization on
their Committed Use Discounts.
And it's very different than
some other discount products
that they've played with.
So the other thing is if
you're growing your deployment,
you may want to come in
and update that over time
to cover as much as your
base usage as makes sense.
So they're flexible.
You can change shapes
whenever you want to.
The discount's not
tied to a specific VM.
You don't have to specify
anything at runtime.
There's no tagging that says
this VM is a Committed Use
Discount.
This one isn't.
The way it works
is we do it fairly.
And what fairly
means is we analyze
this over the entire
time span of your usage.
And at any point
in time, we take
the first x vCPUs, and
the first y gigabytes
of RAM that meet your commitment
and we apply Committed Use
Discount across all of those.
If some VM is
temporarily contributing
to that and that VM
stops and there's
another one that wasn't
in the consideration,
it automatically
gets considered.
So you're always getting
the maximum use of you're
Committed Use Discounts.
And then finally, the
Sustained Use Discount
applies on any usage that's
above that threshold.
So referring to that idea
I mentioned a minute ago
of the low watermark,
if you know
where your baseline is and
you see some usage over that,
you can rest assured that
that usage will still
qualify for Sustained
Use Discounts
if it is a significant
enough period of the month
to qualify in a normal sense.
So this was one of the quotes
from our launch article,
just to give you a sense of
what our customers thought
about that.
I think we kind of hit the mark.
I like the last
sentence the most.
So another recipe.
Last year in this talk I would
have said Leverage Preemptible
VMs.
This is my favorite product.
This is our best product.
This is also the
very first product
I launched when I got to
Google, so I might be biased.
But we introduced this
over three years ago.
And the concept
is really simple.
If your workload can
tolerate interruptions,
then we will give you up to
80% off of the cost of the VM
for you to run a Preemptible VM.
There's no auctions.
There's no bidding.
There's no uncertainty, except
there is a small chance--
usually around 10%--
that you might get
preempted with some of your
VMs earlier than the 24 hour
window.
So if your workload
is prepared for that,
this is a great option.
Now, the reason I'm
not saying VMs anymore
is because our customers have
told us they love this idea.
In fact, I was walking
over here earlier,
and a customer was telling
me, we love Preemptible VMs.
We can't get enough of them.
We extended this to
our other resources.
This is now a general pricing
concept in our infrastructure
layer of preemptible resources.
You can also see it reflected
into higher level services that
use preemptible such as GKE.
So beyond CPU and
RAM, we now have
GPUs that you can
get preemptible,
Cloud TPUs that you can get
preemptible, and local SSD.
So what those mean is if those
are attached to a Preemptible
VM, you will get the preemptible
price on those resources.
And the other rules around the
preemptible shutting down early
are the same.
Now, one other thing.
I had a slide that I
was preparing for this.
I didn't quite get a
chance to throw it in.
We made an announcement
today, which
may have gotten
lost in the noise
of many other announcements,
that the Cloud TPU prices here
are actually wrong.
There's a promotional price
going on right now where that
normal price is $4.50 and
the PVM price, I believe,
is down to $1.35.
So check that out if you're
interested in Cloud TPUs.
But in general, we
continue extending this.
And you may see it in
other places in the future.
So lastly, we'll do a little
Q&A. Thinking about tooling,
how do you use all this stuff?
How do you know
that you're getting
the savings you hope for?
So the first key-- and
I put this one first,
not necessarily because it's
the first thing you're going
to use, but it's the first thing
that I recommend that you do--
is run to the Cloud
Platform console
when you start setting
up your project,
turn on BigQuery Export.
Now, I will tell you, this
comes with a small cost.
It is going to store
some data in BigQuery,
and you have to pay
for that storage.
But the advantage is if you
turn this on right away,
then even if you
don't get around
to starting deep analysis of
your costs for a few months,
all that data will be there
in BigQuery waiting for you.
So I'd highly
recommend you do that.
It gives you much
more information.
And there's a bunch of tools
that you can use that leverage
BigQuery that will go
much better for you
than extremely dense
spreadsheets, which
is what everybody
seems to use otherwise.
So I can't underscore
that enough.
Second of all, I don't
know what this picture is.
I was thinking maybe it was like
King Tut's tomb or something
and the different rooms.
No, actually, this is a
slide I stole from the IO 118
talk, which I believe
is the one that
already happened this morning.
But that talk is all about
how to organize your resources
using the different features
we have, such as organization
nodes, projects,
folders, labels,
so that you can do really
meaningful analysis of how
your utilization is working.
So I definitely recommend
checking out that talk.
And it starts, like I said,
at the two person shop
and builds up to a large
organization, multiple billing
accounts, those kinds of things.
So it's great to
get a sense of, how
do I organize this so
I can analyze it later?
Finally, we have some
features around being
able to set budgets
and then being
able to get alerts and
notifications on those.
And then you can have
automated responses as well.
And so this is a slide that
I stole from the IO103 talk,
which has not happened yet.
So I would definitely
recommend checking out
Stephen's talk as well.
And there's a rundown of all
the different sessions that
talk more about all
the different billing
techniques and tools that you
can use to understand cost.
I would also recommend--
which one is it--
I believe it's IO208 that has
a customer named Vendasta.
It's Dale and Dale
from Vendasta,
and they're very funny guys.
And their talk is,
look at all the--
as described by them yesterday--
look at all the stuff
we did wrong.
Here's how we found it.
Don't do this.
So it's pretty interesting
sort of lessons learned
about analysis and billing.
Things where they
found, oh, look.
We were storing 10
terabytes of extra log data
that we didn't know about.
And the list goes on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]